we actually got some footage of you guys
in the backyard some cats in the wild
here
okay oh [ __ ] there's brendan with the
wig
[Laughter]
oh the power
is that us are you guys starting a
competing business yeah you're back hold
on the baby backs are dope
oh wow the boys are living you guys were
i'm jack
oh these guys must be rich huh where do
they live at
that really does look like me noises the
boys are dope
i'm with it i'm with it um
you've been doing shows have you have
you guys been either y'all been doing
shows during this
uh with brandon oh that's right you guys
went on the road to the
arizona went arizona was it normal
super you know what a little too normal
that's why i got covered
we don't have to show this i don't
understand why this is uh what's this
well this is this is when you kind of
like i didn't know what i was doing
oh you posted this well i just want to
show like don't ever be afraid to attack
the bear that's what i wanted
here's the thing dude you got to drive
with your legs man you got to hang them
on the wall who filmed this
yeah i don't know i guess kevin
kevin is not i know
kevin would never work here this is
insane it's hard to see who who's
winning
when i was winning up top and then when
he dropped the camera that's when you
kind of like
bring into the movie but here's the
thing they're they keep
[ __ ] with me and then hopefully
wrestle friday i'm like i don't want to
wrestle on friday dude
i'm not about to go on stage like just
wrestle friday morning all right man
let's get it over with
oh can in san antonio no footage
i did a better job i handled it you
could do a better day yeah i handled my
there yeah that's a nice picture i
appreciate it are you doing comedy are
you
modeling and i don't know i'm doing both
a lot of people say i got good
like a good chess ratio so i just wanted
to keep posting that
oh wow appreciate you man do a lot of
people think that you
are um somebody's brother and it's the
wrong person
yeah always i always always get the uh
it's always two people right
it's either lance gross or michael b
jordan wow
and honestly i don't look like either
one yeah have you ever seen michael b
jordan yeah exactly like he was in
friday night lights
yeah and the wire yeah he was awesome
that looks like he used wallace yeah he
was wallace
i got to watch it again i missed him he
was in creed too
you kind of look like that no i don't
look like him i wouldn't say you look
[Laughter]
michael c jordan that's better than that
the c jordan yeah look at michael j
plus give him a c ladies
michael c joy i didn't like that d
plus a little bit theo i thought we was
both from louisiana you could at least
gave me a little higher grade you're
right man i have a tendency to throw
people under the
under the d-plus
pretty good that was almost good
i have tendency to throw people under
the d-plus bus
um i just don't know what to say man
dude do you ever have them
[Laughter]
i don't know man i sent an email before
this show that i definitely should not
have sent so this whole time i'm just
thinking god i wish i'd not
to me send an email
oh no because you know theo man if it's
before 9 00 am that email ain't gonna be
nice
it's
if it's before noon it's it ain't nice
notes i don't answer the phone before 11
when you call it bro
this almost feels like an intervention
because everybody in here set for you
yeah i've emailed before 9am and even
before
4am
[Laughter]
if it's an early morning or email
and i called theo on it we started
arguing he was man my batman let's just
let's not talk before noon anymore
and we don't i do some of my worst work
between the hours of 1 a.m
and 3 p.m that means
a big window it is three people oh
no so it's just it's on your mind oh
it's just like
way i can feel like other people at the
end of this email just getting furious
[Laughter]
was it a business email yeah yeah it was
a business email man
a lot business here than me
so anyone anyone else
i can't wait for the response
[Laughter]
you're consumed with it though yeah it's
just like one of those things it's just
like
weighing in my brain anyway i didn't
mean to bring it up i'm not trying to
sidetrack the show but i wanted to just
let you know what i was thinking about
no that's fair man you're dealing with
that you know
oh yeah it'll be fine man i just don't
like doing
it i'll tell you what's on my mind
i hate hollywood too but uh [ __ ]
college football might not be going dude
other conferences are jumping out now
and what are they going to shoot the lsu
coach going hard in the paint
yes football yeah yeah sec might just do
their own thing
they should mine as well what's the best
political now you look at you know the
pac-12 bunch of [ __ ] mainly
democratic states
uh who else the big ten the big ten tans
out
but then ohio state was like all right
we'll just go play somewhere else
exactly they did
yeah they're like we'll jump in the sec
nebraska was like oh you want to cancel
we'll jump with sec so you might just
get one baller ass conference fine
finally man i wish that uh i wish that
some of the schools don't need to be
playing anymore no when connecticut was
like
connected i think we're out this year
like we don't give a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
what is it what is the black community
saying about football are you guys there
we still good you guys are good yeah 100
but i mean we're on and off because og
obj he just said uh it should be we
should be banning football this year
really like a lot of black obj yeah yeah
he was like we shouldn't be playing the
guy that killed uh
odell beckham said we should cancel
football yeah
well for one he's on the cleveland
browns so let's just add that in
and two right so yeah who and two he's
so they're already
taking it easy on that correct and but
i'm saying a lot of black lives he's
like yo
he's trying to like care about the
players i was like you got helmet and
gloves on you can't catch it
right and if you catch it you can
probably get rid of it
you can get somebody else's blood if you
want you know what i'm saying
yeah a lot of players these days it's
like they don't even want to be players
anymore they want to be players for the
clout but they don't want to be players
you mean everyone wants to be calling
kaepernick and actually or everybody
yeah or people turn in a little bit more
of an activist i feel like sometimes but
i don't know maybe they're also really
scared i mean black and latino people
get that does get
vi the chronovirus if you're in shape
though yeah if you're in shape they they
get it and they
they pass it you know it's not it's not
that big of a deal the kids in college
are more likely to die
driving to the campus than from corona
oh wow yeah and you got a lot of nice
statements
nick saban said their players they're
safer at
uh alabama then at home because you can
get it from a borah hanging out
but all this is these [ __ ] ass owners
who are not owners but like the
the regents and all that who who run the
colleges they
they know what's gonna happen they just
if one person dies they don't want it on
their hands
that's all they don't give a [ __ ] about
but if you go to college somebody you
know dies man
somebody's dying bro by going to college
some parents send their [ __ ] kids to
college be like this little
we don't even care about this you don't
let that kid join a frat yeah
eating dog eating dog food yeah
damn damn that's what they do i don't
know i never went through it but i know
those boys get saucy
well they die all the time well they
yeah because they freaking party hard
bro
the hardest yeah that's as hard as you
can party you die yeah you're right
that's game over but did you die and
they're like yeah
okay yeah yeah my friend did god
have a few friends that did yeah they
were pledging and alan died
you're like troy died
that's such a brat name yeah dude troy
passed away
the worst is when somebody's named troy
yeah brett did pass away
the worst is it for somebody named troy
they uh
call themselves t-roy t-roy that's too
much
t-roy went too hard big brother t-roy
t-roy's bad what do you think ari what
are you what are you hearing uh
on the spectrum over there about um
uh see my family were just a little it's
scary to look at it's dangerous
football is a pretty dangerous like ct
yeah ct i mean i it's fun to watch but i
would never play it did you play you
were in military school did you guys
play in military school they had a team
we were actually it was mandatory to go
to the game so i would watch every game
and yeah the whole time just like ah
military school did you go to college
too yeah what's
you see santa cruz bananas oh she went
the opposite way military to hippie
and banana slugs are racial slur now
also isn't it it could be
yeah like an asian thing i'm not sure i
wasn't even thinking about that but now
yellow right he could pick any color
almost and call him a banana sauce
now your school got famous from pulp
fiction yeah that shirt
uh yeah scientologists
then they sold a bunch of teas
i'll get you some do you so do you
think anything about football i don't
watch it i'm not going to
sit here and pretend like i follow
football so you don't care if it happens
or not
no yeah i say let it happen i want
things to be like normal yeah
so i think if it happened before i want
it to happen yeah what about
was nashville normal let me see compared
to l.a
because la is the worst right yeah
things were more open there things were
more open
uh you could go to restaurants um
i went and swam in like a lake out at
this place piercy priest park
where you just pull up and just like
remember that lake we swam in oklahoma
uh-huh
uh just like that kind of place so you
just pull up dirty fat kids
yeah nice
some kids have their shirts on yeah some
kind of shirts on yeah i love that
a lot of kids are sure they should all
leave them on it especially in today's
time with like
yeah with comedians
[Laughter]
i just want kids that should be a rule
kids have to keep their shirts on at all
times
um yeah i'm trying to think so yeah went
out to some restaurants
did you eat did you get any good
nashville uh oh yeah chicken hot
sandwiches
i went to this place called edly's what
it was called there's some real famous
place out there deadly's east that's
what it's called nick
italy's east and i got a straight up
yeast infection in my stomach guys
it was good dude yeah oh that's barbecue
yeah i'm talking about that natural hot
chicken scent oh
dave's had chicken no not and the boss
boy there is a fan of the show landon
shout out landon a little ginger
a little sun victor bro yeah yeah
little sun kiss here yeah this guy
yeah little fella he was over there
yeah i forget the name it's right
downtown though it's right in the city
there's
chick nashville chicken hot sandwiches
remember what's
up that's what you call it there's a
line up the goddamn door colin raised
right helen ray's
oh the one here in chinatown yeah it's
helen race no this race there's also a
national hockey tatty bees for [ __ ]
sakes
how do you be patty b holland raises
here now
is um there's a lot like two hour line
yeah and i just got called for pick up
for hot chicken it's fantastic the best
hot chicken you have
i i think howling bees but what do you
mean here's what i understand
yeah what they mean hot chicken i'm
talking about that deep fried chicken
breast
doused in hot sauce bro with pickles a
bun
wash it down with a nice dr pepper maybe
a big red i don't know
today's sponsor yeah bro you losing your
hair
you got some erectile dysfunction you
got a cold how about you need some coven
19 home test
well him said
swing low sweet dog
sherman oh hems yeah hymns hems up man
my bad 66 percent of men start to lose
their hair by age
35 check yep check not really but it's
going into my eyebrows whatever
listen hams helps you guys thanks to
science hair loss can be optional
brendan let me tell them i have erectile
dysfunction
okay i have lost my hair i've seen hair
in the sink hair in my bed
i don't own a cat what's happening limp
wiener lamp wiener i've woken up in the
middle of the night and
shined a light on my wiener and seen it
sleeping on my thigh and then wake up
get up yeah map's over you've been
napping for weeks yeah and i'll put a
thing of soap in a sock and beat it with
it like yeah like a metal
like full metal jacket yeah you want
don't full metal jacket your dick
anymore man
use hims right now few quick questions
with a real licensed medical
professional
and for free they'll do all that and see
if you get fda approved products to
treat hair loss
and your erectile dysfunction they
approve it and it shows up at your
doorstep
a little package discreet package if
you're not happy dude after 90 days
just email him you get a full refund
yeah and look here's the thing guys
you want to take the best chance you can
to have good wiener to have
good hair you want to take that best why
wouldn't you put your best
foot forward yeah would you give a child
a vitamin then give you a wiener a
little vitamin go to for hims.com
kats that's for hims.com
cats full refund and price paid
available for first 90 days supply
refund requests must be made between 90
and
80 days after product shipment
prescription products require an online
consultation with a medical professional
who will determine if prescription is
appropriate
restrictions apply to a website for
details and important safety information
i've always wanted to do that let's
start dips
yeah let's get into this show man thank
you guys for joining us today
for having us thank you for having me we
already uh
watched one cats in a while theo
actually sent me this one he caught me
it's at the end of this video uh my
short stint as a server
[Music]
god damn
[Music]
oh this is girl
[Music]
oh
this is how people die in college
short stint it looked like they tried to
make a really cool video and just gave
up
like we're going to show all the mess
that [ __ ] was dope yeah it started off
really hot and it got weird
and let's focus in one more time on nick
losing his job at a fridays
[Laughter]
so what happens is one kind of tip see
there
that was the final
[Laughter]
hey bro i'm dealing with a lot
bro oh god man i can't even imagine i
sent that email
[Laughter]
you gotta show me that dude i can't wait
[Music]
is